I think women can do anything
Wow I mean just because they can doesn't
mean they should right I think about
women fixing cars driving a taxi
installing some drywall why not
no look trust me a girl like you you
don't really want this a girl like me
hmm I mean I want all my options
available so I can decide for myself
miss independent that's right it's me I
love it mm-hmm
Oh mmm except you're sitting here eating
my food enjoying my view better ice no I
chose you to join me I chose to make you
notice me uh mm-hmm that is not your
choice to be enough mmm that is God's
gift to you but don't you think it's
sort of what you do with those gifts
that really matters every one of us
mm-hmm men women we all just want to
fulfill our potential live our heart's
desires and that's the kind of world I
want to live in um well my world is me
making millions with you by my side it's
just that I'm so good at so many things
oh yeah yeah like what
well at my job
it's actually considered a huge
advantage to be a woman yeah yeah if
you're beautiful
nothing else is really expected of you
if you're not yeah pretty much rendered
invisible and in my line of work
mmm invisibility law expectations they
come in very handy though
but as donut the councii knowing as you
do I'd add nice here Donuts Gaza so no
way I mean you're Scalia Allen Street
project is you know yeah that's it
[Music]
did you know what it takes men an
additional seven seconds to perceive a
woman as a threat compared to a man
[Music]
you still hate money cheese impediment
you must be the accountants who are you
- safe everything in the bottom row
let's go you're not cut out for this I
recommend and you might have work what
about Australian Johnny oh you're gonna
regret this it's gonna give you the well
thing is you just talk way too much
you're super Klingon you've come on way
too strong you're the most incredible
woman that I know so that's four months
surveillance two countries and the most
embarrassing date I have ever been on in
my life are we good I will address this
to the US Justice Department along with
all your new friends here we're good to
go
see I'm not here man I'm gonna take a
week off party my ass off on a Thai
beach Jane you should give a shot
beaches blend someone play with your uh
I have fun in my own ways oh cool you
sharpen your samurai swords at night
cosplay Catwoman I'd actually pay to see
at night
that was funny so how will I you were in
the presence of angels but the question
is Johnny who are you
[Music]
hands up got two bands up got your head
held high like you starstruck you want
watch you know how to run a backup you
know you go in the race telling ketchup
Trump plays they're gonna feel amazing
knowing that to the rungs are not the
pavement that's that everything's better
done you have made it you never stopped
I know that's what I hate in a non shout
outs are the real ones with the bases
loaded but two home runs
[Music]
[Music]
Ingrid you were late mr. Flemming is
waiting oh I was in the meeting set for
9 yes 9 a.m. is when the meeting starts
which is exactly now have you ever spent
time with him mr. brach no first time he
had me over to his chateau which is in
France and we were sitting there and I'm
asking him I said mr. brach have you
heard of Humphrey Davy any judge no I
say have you ever heard of Joseph Swan
or Alexander ludian no clue so I say
okay what about Thomas Edison well of
course
who hasn't he invented the light bulb
right but guess what so did those other
three guys before Edison but Edison was
first to market do you see my point we
have a product that will revolutionize
the power industry but we have to be
first the time is now and that's what I
told mr. Brock and he agrees with me
obviously I thank you so much for coming
in I love how this conversation went
well technically I haven't said anything
oh let's not get caught in a game of who
said what
right mr. Fleming I know how important
kalisto is okay I'm the lead programmer
on it it's my baby
yeah but as I wrote in my report right
now there is a possibility for the
harmonic range to be reversed and and we
both know how dangerous that could be
well I mean you don't know what I know
you know you know who we are the second
engineer he's actually still in hospital
after a brain seizure and he was only
partially accelerates allegedly and
Julio wasn't it it all I need is root
access and some time to permanently fix
the flaw in the blockchain so that it
will stay safe in grid can I get a
cappuccino okay I read your report I've
had others read your report we just
simply disagree with you as mr. Brock
read my report because I really think
that it may be crystal clear here we
have developed Callisto for five years
and we are going to market it is safe
and it is ready and that's what we're
telling mr. Brock and you are telling
mr. Brock
nothing
look Elena you're much too smart to keep
pushing this forward aren't you I knew
who Humphrey Davy was good for you you'd
rep something out no that's not mine
well I don't litter so it must be yours
you might need it
[Music]